before we get to today's video topic i
wanted to say thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video
regardless of whether you prescribe to
hustle culture or not
it's really important to protect your
data and identity
when you go online nordvpn is a super
easy vpn service to use
nordvpn has super fast servers in fact
they have over 5560 countries and you
can have
up to six simultaneous connections they
don't do any data logging and they have
double data encryption for increased
anonymity
and they've got some wonderful policies
like a 30-day money-back guarantee and
24 7 customer support so make sure to go
to nordvpn.com
mayuko or use code mayuko to get a
two-year plan
plus one additional month with a huge
discount hey everyone how's it going my
name is mayuko and welcome back to my
channel where we talk about tech career
and life
on another episode of mayuko talks about
stuff that's been on our mind for a
while after working in tech but didn't
even really know
how to talk about it or even what was
really bothering her but
now it's really starting to pour out of
her we're going to talk about my
experience
working in tech and content creation and
its relation to hustle culture
hustle culture and tech industry feel
kind of synonymous to me
like by working in tech you are hustling
also as a youtuber i feel like it's
pretty common for there to be some sort
of hustling element to it too
and what i mean hustling or hustling
culture i'm talking about
overworking yourself for your job or
making money
basically pushing yourself past your
limits to reach this sort of
capitalist utopia or evolved version of
human that doesn't need to eat or sleep
or something
and like me where you go at 28 years old
realize that i don't really prescribe to
hustle culture
and let me tell you why there was a time
when i tried prescribing to hustle
culture
especially when i was working at a
startup
i had a daily three-hour commute and i
was trying to optimize
all of my time at work and otherwise to
not only get
[ __ ] done but i guess to hustle but then
like the panic attacks came at first i
thought it was just like
one-off instances of panic but after
months and years of therapy
i now realized that through the panic
attacks my brain was sending me warning
signals
and putting my brain into a state of
just like oh my gosh i'm literally dying
right now because that's what panic
attacks feel like and i think it had a
lot to do with the fact that i wasn't
really truly taking care of myself
like hustling to me means that you're
ignoring some basic structures of
balance between
work and not work and my panic attacks
were a result of that balance being
way off aka i was not only investing too
much time but also too much energy in my
work
so yeah now i can see that my own
personal balance has to be
much better than what i was doing so i
thought a lot about
how i got there in adopting hustle
culture
and why it's so common and hyped up in
the worlds that i was living in
like what is hustle culture even for it
promises this sort of
utopia that we're i guess trying to
reach in which our whole self is defined
by the work we do
and that's the mark we leave on this
planet not just for society but for
ourselves and our future generations
people also talk about getting out of
the rat race but like
is doing so actually going to bring
happiness and to that i say
yeah for some probably for some folks
hustle culture whether they define it as
that or not
is how they've oriented their whole life
to be around
slash about when i tried to adopt hustle
culture i thought that by hustling
my life was more purposeful it had like
a framework to live by
and i also had like a reason to live and
to go up and get out of bed every
morning
but kind of like how i mentioned in my
previous video i feel like i then
started to interpret it as
if i'm not hustling then i'm without a
defined reason and purpose to live
so i don't deserve to be happy or just
to exist
or achieve my dreams which that's some
harmful self-talk you know i mean being
japanese and american
i feel like i'm from two cultures that
glamorize the
out of hustling and working hard and
from what i've seen
from both cultures about hustling and
working hard
it just felt like their definition of
happiness or their life purpose
didn't really align with mine i just
realized that it's just like
not really what i aspire to or want to
achieve
especially now that i'm older and know
myself better now
to go deeper i feel like part of hustle
culture is to make yourself some sort of
work
machine and in this effort to automate
and optimize your life
there's this need to quantify results
like the need to literally
measure everything everything from the
amount of hours that you've worked
to the ounces of water you've had to the
amount of sleep you get a night
and i think that's because in order to
optimize your life you need to like
measure the current state first i guess
i see the stark parallel in the tech
industry where
companies and tech people are constantly
measuring things like
are we hitting our metrics did we
accomplish enough story points this
sprint
is our product slash company growing
quickly enough
how many people are using this feature
and is it driving up engagement
even in the content creation world there
is also this sense of needing to measure
quantitative results to verify
legitimacy
did enough people watch my videos did
enough people click
through is that click-through rate high
enough
do i have enough subscribers i mean
measuring quantifiable results
is great in that it helps to make sense
of the ambiguity
in a world where no one really knows
what they're doing
and we're all kind of making it up as we
go
and make sure that we're headed towards
the right direction
allows us to easily share contacts with
others and gives us something to work
towards
but in reflecting on all this i thought
will reaching some quantifiable goal
really give me the life or career that i
want
because if i had to look back on my work
as a software engineer and content
creator
the stuff that i remember the stuff that
matters
the stuff that really made me feel glad
about choosing this path
is the qualitative stuff each individual
story you all send me about your life
and what role my content has played
every person
i was able to meet and work with in the
process of creating something
at the end of the day when it comes to
quantitative insights
i'm not going to ignore it completely
being able to track data that way
is a really useful tool in doing
business in the 21st century
i mean after all i do need to keep tabs
on whether people are actually using or
watching my stuff
but if i had to balance out which side
was more important to me
it would be the qualitative stuff it's a
work in progress as i challenge this
position and notion that i've brought
with me from the tech industry
into my work as a content creator but
i'm constantly reminding myself
that it's the qualitative stuff and that
more isn't necessarily better
it's quality it's thoughtfulness it's
intentionality
that makes good and i don't know
i guess this position just feels very
counterculture to hustle culture
where a lot of it is about maxing
ourselves out like machines
i said in my previous video that we as a
whole human being
are not just our work and our worth
isn't
shouldn't be calculated by the things we
create because
we all inherently deserve to exist and
be happy regardless of those things
instead i'm choosing to look at my life
based on a lot of things like did i eat
something good today
did i rest well do i feel like i did
good work today that moves me towards
the future that i want
did i give everything a solid try
everybody's
different and i definitely acknowledge
the huge amount of privilege i have in
being able to live this way
and people will just choose to live
however they want based on who they are
and what their circumstances are and
that's fine but this is who i
am and you know i'm gonna live my life
in a way that matters to me
thanks all so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the video first of all make sure
to pre-order your code hoodie i hope you
enjoyed them
this video was inspired by a
conversation i had as a guest on a
podcast called the work item so i'll
leave the full episode link in the
description box down below
make sure to subscribe for more musings
about tech career and life for me and
i'll see you next time